well you know i i definitely think world
war iii is an interesting topic but it
is friday so maybe we should actually
tone things down and talk about world
war 4
the next one now this one will be a bit
more chill and we'll uh we'll have a
good friday night fox news reports
warner brothers removes dialogue from
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore in china the move comes after
the studio received a request to remove
lines referencing dumbledore's gay
relationship my understanding is that
that's like the main plot of the movie
but brett you saw it so sad last night
yeah so spoiler alerts i guess
the secret is that dumbledore's gay
which really wasn't yeah
i know no wait wait wait wait wait wait
i'm sorry i'm sorry the movie is called
the secrets of dumbledore and the secret
is that he's gay basically but that
secret was already spoiled years ago
because jk rowling was kind of when was
that maybe three years ago that she was
like oh yeah he's gay and a couple of
the other characters you know or
non-binary whatever
still everybody hates her regardless um
but yeah i think here's the thing i love
harry potter the movie was
mediocre it was subpar and there were
like three kind of gay points throughout
it like it started off with some and
there were some like innuendos in like
the middle part and then at the end like
you see dumbledore and grindelwald kind
of like have their moment of like who
will i love now
no they're just like they're fighting
but because they are connected
because
i forget what happened in the first one
but they were like blood is connected
because they were lovers or something
like that they technically can't like
destroy each other well that's crazy
yeah because like in harry potter
there's like
how how is it that no one who ever once
loved another person ever fought until
now yeah like you have to imagine that
would come up quite a bit
you know it's like that's my axe
i can't fight her because you know
it reminds me of the same thing when uh
like voldemort and harry are fighting in
the wands like
come like combustible yeah if you use
that kind of thing it was that sword it
was a similar vibe i don't know exactly
what lines they removed removed
obviously because they didn't watch the
chinese version
but uh doesn't that make the movie not
work if they remove that from the movie
i feel like i don't know what the other
secret would be it was like the i don't
like what then what would the whole plot
be it was very it was just kind of like
taking down grindelwald but there really
was nothing going on they add like one
scene at the end where after the movie
ends they're like but wait what was the
secret dumbledore and then he like pulls
up his underwear it's got roses he's
like i'm wearing rose underwear and
they're like oh that's the secret i love
it
i guess the other there was another
because dumbledore's brother is in it so
there is another dumbledore and he kind
of has like a storyline where there is a
secret that's not gay so i technically
think if you remove that there is
another oh they meant dumbledore they
were referring to the non the non main
character dumbledore yes the ancillary
character dumbledore and the title of
the film one of the things you mentioned
that really bugs me is you know i think
star wars did it they ripped off the
star wars episode four the first star
was ever made with the what was it
episode
seven seven eight nine it was seven i
think they just re-just redid the story
but like in a different form it was it
was a shot for shot remake basically so
the force awakens is like a new hope
did it feel like they did that with
harry potter was it different enough it
was it was different enough it was not
as good the magic was fantastic though i
mean it's interesting going back and
like watching the original movies and
it's like i remember growing up being
like oh this is so epic and it's like oh
that's kind of campy now
it'd be wondering like that did that
secret make it to like oh you kind of
broke the fourth wall this is about this
is too much about this world not not
enough about that world you could
definitely tell one thing that i learned
was that this i think was pretty sure
people can correct me if i'm wrong this
was the first harry potter film that was
produced by hollywood rather than
british and i don't know i mean you
could tell there was something about it
that i was just like it didn't feel
right it didn't feel like it really sat
in the universe maybe that was it but it
was kind of like the last one
what if they just you know so jk
rowling's been doing these screenplays
the books she wrote were fantastic i
love the harry potter series seems like
these screenplays are just the worst
trash i've ever seen in like terrible
movies is she writing the screenplays
i'm pretty sure she wrote the
screenplays it wouldn't be funny if they
just like they announced the new series
and it's effectively like star wars a
shot-for-shot remake of of the
sorcerer's stone or whatever but at the
end it's like the secret isn't the
sorcerer's stone it's just like some
woke trash about the character was
actually a white supremacist oh
you know
did you see the new lord of the rings
movie on i think it's on amazon um and
that's a series right yeah yeah the
series and i saw a screenshot showed
like a hundred and seventy thousand down
votes and like ten thousand up votes or
something and that all these people
comment on it's the videos on youtube
and it's a quote from jrr tolkien that
says evil can never create anything new
it can only twist and destroy what's
already been created
the book the master switch goes into
what hollywood has been doing lately you
notice that almost everything's a remake
it's it's this algorithm that's saying
we we know how to predict how
continually making spider-man
continually making batman and wolverine
and all that stuff we know how to
predict that and i think that's also
going to dovetail into these like uh did
you guys see what was that ready player
one
okay
there there was that racing game where
there's godzilla and i think there's
also king kong they're gonna immortalize
these like archetypal characters in
these games to live forever so they they
become like almost like these fictitious
gods and goddesses from the movies
and um i just want to say one thing like
voldemort you mentioned
the the two other names that are um like
in russian similar to that is of
vladimir and uh like voldemort
and so like i i keep hearing that
relation between vladimir and voldemort
so that was anti-russian propaganda i
have no idea jk rowling what did you do
he knew the news trending tomorrow
is that really it's like the son of son
of superman and but he's like he's a guy
i think they were talking about doing
that with james bond i think they were
gonna do a non-binary the producer was
like yeah they were like oh well we're
not ruling out that bond could be a
a non-binary legit would love to make
short films
that you know in no way disparage
anybody but just make the point where
it's like
we take james bond we do an action scene
and then in the end the bad guy goes
james
are you gay and he goes yes and that's
the end of it it's like
you know and i don't know i don't say
that to this is not a critique of the
lgbtq community it's a critique of
hollywood just like to predict how they
would play these movies out how they
would do character development instead
of being like here here's what i like i
like it when there's character
development
and uh uh
you you you understand the character or
you relate to a certain emotion what i
don't like is when they're just like
dumbledore's gay
it's like okay look you know if
dumbledore as part of the plot was in
love with a guy i'd be like oh okay like
show me the motivation help me
understand it if the secret of the movie
is literally that dumbledore likes men
and they've been hammering this point
i'm just like guys you didn't make a
movie you made just make a commercial
where it ends with dumbledore saying
he's gay a social social point rather
than good writing i was gonna say so
from the like the back side of it
because i was next for 10 years and then
while i was in college my whole plan had
been to like then go into production and
be a producer and that's what i wanted
to do so i was working at i was working
at an academy award-winning production
company it was an indie
company and what i loved about it was
that it was they only produced like
deeply like character-driven narratives
like brilliant stories and during
blm i was working with them around cobit
as well
everything swapped and instead of i was
on like the development team so my part
of my job was reading every single
script uh submission that we would get
and breaking it down and it switched
from brett tell us about the character
motivations and what makes these
characters tick what do we learn from it
what is the audience grasping at the end
like the things that i think are
important too
do we have a native american story we
don't have this we i mean we scrapped
like 70 of the projects that we had
agreed to fund and do because they did
not tick off enough of the boxes did
ownership change or was it was just like
we're not going to produce so it was
just like went back to the screenwriters
like we can't do it and then my job
became not let's like seek out these
fantastic new writers you know read
whatever comes in it was like you need
to actively go find things that we can
acquire
that are like a trans you know female
native american story so that we can be
the social justice whatever i mean it
truly got so separated
from what i think is the most beautiful
part of entertainment why i love
entertainment why i love you know movies
and storytelling it was truly just
you know let's check a political box was
it like the ownership of the when i
asked about the ownership of the company
that you worked at did they change oh no
different people they're just they just
started acting differently yeah
socially
well you know what i was thinking is is
it possible that you know maybe in the
past 10 or 15 years
uh a species of small slugs
descended on earth and crawled into
people's ears and started to attach
themselves and take over their their
their minds and bodies is is that one
way it may have happened yeah what are
those 50 percent what are those little
space bears
this kind of came up with ben shapiro he
was on the show a couple days ago we did
an afternoon show it's gonna be on
timcast.com i think on sunday it's gonna
be on we'll put on youtube okay cool
and we were talking about just basically
facts and how can you convince succumb
sometimes you just can't convince people
of things and i think when someone's
really agitated like when someone's
really emotionally calm
facts speak volumes it's easy to pay
attention and change your mind and you
know change your thoughts when you're
agitated and crazy almost nothing can
make you stabilize like no matter what
comes up it doesn't matter because
you're freaking out and if like this
wi-fi is freaking all this this this
energy that we're pouring through the
air is like causing people to go nuts
haywire i don't know the word
and so they're they're not able to stay
cool when things like you were saying
social engineering when things like blm
and it may even have contributed the
rise of these social movements but i
think that's more like a ccp long war
game but that it's just overly impacting
people
because of the environment that's why
it's when people say oh we just need to
like how do you convince people of you
know how do you red pill them whatever
it's like just speak the truth it's like
you can't just do that like we can you
know talk about facts all day long but
if you are not meeting people on their
own turf if you're not you know doing
what daily wire does and creating
culture what tim cast does all of this
um if you are not you know communicating
with them in a way that is relatable and
tangible and engaging and you know is
taking into account emotions especially
with the younger generations where we
are
all hell is breaking loose at all time
like you you cannot just convince people
with facts alone it has to be
when you were growing up did it feel
like all hell was breaking loose when
you were younger too not at all but i
was in a very
i don't know not contained environment
but i just didn't i didn't go to public
school i was homeschooled for my entire
life yeah yeah that's great um i went to
i went to public school for three years
i did kindergarten
first grade maybe second grade and then
i did my freshman year of high school
and i was like this place is awful and i
left so as a result i was not in the
midst of all of that
i saw it when i got to college and while
i was working in hollywood but i think i
was so you know focused on my own
internal whatever that it just didn't
even phase me
um oh yeah i want to go back to your
point you said about you know facts and
convincing people actually think that
facts typically play a small role that's
almost always emotion
so you want to make someone feel
something when i was doing when i worked
in fundraising for non-profits it's all
emotion if you go to someone and you'd
say
you know hi i'd like to give you some
facts about this catastrophe we're
facing did you know that every day we do
x y and z and this is where they're
gonna be like yeah okay thanks have a
nice day no you've gotta they say the
first thing is create a sense of urgency
ah that's right you have to convince
them something is imperiled now
you can't just tell them the truth you
have to create create they would say
create a sense of urgency and you have
to make them personally invested in it
you have to make them there's several
ways you can do it there's things like
if we're going to talk about a far away
land we have to make you to blame
because why would you care about a far
away land oh because it's your fault if
we're going to talk about an issue that
does affect you then you're the victim
here and you've got to help fight back
like we got we got to hold these people
accountable there's always a way to
emotionally trigger someone
either through a demand for justice or
through guilt there's an emotion you're
trying to target to make them take a
certain action i hated that industry
it's what i was doing before this little
this is what i was doing this summer was
doing like copywriting and you know what
is it called i for you i worked for an
organization and did it but where you're
writing you know the
pages yep and fundraising letters and
all of that stuff like there is
basically a blueprint that you follow to
get boomers to donate money to you
these blueprints are typically they're
formulaic they're typically trash
but the formula is right they just what
they do is they know the formula there's
actually a step-by-step process so these
companies will give you a sheet and
it'll it'll give you five boxes and
it'll explain which each box needs to do
and then you write in those boxes
you know how would you convey the idea
so it says like one introduction two
sense of urgency three problem four
solution five pitch
and then you're like you know they say
follow this formula write it out
a lot of companies will pre-write these
things hoping that if they hire 100
people give them the script 20 of them
make it the rest get fired a week later
and so you know i always thought those
were trash because people don't like you
you'll see them on the street like hi
how are you doing i'm so and so working
with such and such we have a huge
problem blah blah blah it's all boring
and formulaic if you know how to read
people
how they move how they act
then this job becomes insanely easy but
it is almost always an emotional
argument you're either trying to
convince them that you're cool and right
and they should be on your side trying
to convince them that their their they
should be guilty for being at fault for
contributing to this or that someone is
screwing them over you're never just
saying do you care about the environment
yes
what's the most concerning thing to you
one of the problems we're fighting is
deforestation are you concerned about
the removal of trees in large numbers
people will be like i'm sorry i don't
have time for this and they'll leave but
if you say something like
when you go and and you know do x y or z
you are destroying every step of the way
i know you don't mean to do it none of
us do
but don't you think that you should you
know help clean it up a little bit of
course you should i know you're a good
person right you don't you're not the
kind of person who's going to make a
mess at someone's house and leave it
there would you of course not okay
credit card please
i wonder and i've been again i ask you
because you're one of my favorite people
on earth um
uh you're very intelligent just kidding
i don't play favorites i'm talking about
the past is there like some history
logical you know reason that we're so
tuned into emotion
well i don't think we're hardwired for
fact we're hardwired for story look at
what we've done since time immemorial
sat around told stories you could be
like i'm going to tell you the facts of
my day i hunted this thing and i hunted
that thing but it always ended with the
shaman or the chief or somebody
wrapping it into a mythological story
and there's a mythos that basically
captures every generation every
civilization there's some kind of
narrative
like an overarching narrative one big
one from the bible is that there will be
a savior and be on the lookout for that
savior and i think
that's we are hardwired for narrative
and the thing about what's happening in
the world today i'll just say this
you don't have to get people
uh like if if i wanted to engage your
like um emotions to get you to do
something in the world and then to do
that to large groups of people
destabilizing people's sense of
equilibrium first which is basic
training they did that with me
you get you get the people into a state
of stress it destabilizes their default
mode network it almost puts them into a
psychedelic suggestible like state and
then what seems to be the context things
that i'm not making you do but i'm kind
of filling in the blanks of what's
happening contextually will create a
world viewer like oh [ __ ] because of
everything you just said it i realized
what i have to do and that's
setting up the set and setting
destabilizing use and suggesting and
planting seeds not being overt and on
the nose let's let's let's just
going off what you said this is what i
thought of let me tell you about the
hunt i went on
so i went out into the woods
i had uh
my rifle with me
there were there were some issues
we saw the the buck
i lined it up we got it it was great big
guy
let's try another version so there i was
i'm walking through this mud
i see the beast
massive dim the lights
i get my rifle ready i'm jammed it
notices me
i take the shot we got it we go over
there this thing was magnificent
beautiful the biggest you've ever seen
well which which which would people
prefer to hear all right the second one
yeah the second one you're driving
emotion you're trying to create a sense
of you know what's happening so
storytelling
you know i i think about these uh you
know we play d and d or magic the
gathering or whatever and you've got
these games based on goblins and i'm
like you know why there are stories
about goblins because some guy went to
go sell beans at the market and while
he's walking through the woods he comes
across some ugly dude who's yelling
about something or other and he's like
everybody's always coming here and
messing things up you you this is my
road i've been working on it's like get
out of here dude he walks away when he
goes back home he doesn't say some guy
helped him he goes so i'm walking
through the woods and a vile creature
emerges with a crooked nose and pointed
ears and he snarls
and i'm like back beast and i draw my
blade and so people tell these stories
someone writes it down and draws
pictures and like wow and then we
imagine these these vicious monsters and
these giant you know there i was
fighting the dragon and it's like a
small lizard you know homo florences
that hominid i think those are might be
where goblin the the fantasy goblins
come from those little small humans and
they were i think um they historically
would eat human children like they would
they would steal they found some new
ones a couple of years ago
the most recent ones they found well
yeah this is what i've heard there's
also spa new yeah logical stories of
small people like the menehune in uh
hawaii that uh and also like many of the
islands that apparently built all the
structures before the regular stature
people would get there there's stories
of little people and giants
everywhere native americans
i think they're called the giants right
but like cannibalistic giants
native americans from pennsylvania all
the way down to tennessee actually say
that there's
like giants giants yep like are they are
they weird large humans that are kind of
naked and can all be killed by slicing
the nape of their neck
no no
do you know what i was referencing
oh it's attack on titan oh okay yeah but
you left i was like are you are you
familiar all the guys in the chat are
gonna be like but i guess not so guys
calm down i also i also think you have a
good voice for story you should uh you
should do some voice over like that oh
yeah i'm talking audio i'm dr fauci and
uh freedom tunes yeah i love it but now
that fauci is out of the news cycle i'm
out of work man
well i think this is a great opportunity
for you to start storytelling again well
i i i you know i asked sheamus if he
would let me uh voice nancy pelosi on
his show and i don't think he wants to
but she talks like this like her mouth
is falling from her face i think donald
trump
you know i definitely go over the top
with it on purpose because that's what i
have to do i don't like her okay so
maybe we are
in the psychological world i think it's
a storytelling era where and you're an
actor i was an actor ben i mean you're a
performer i went through acting classes
mainly to learn how to write yeah tim
creator performer yeah but i was just
going to say like i
growing up as an actor i would get a lot
of crap especially from like family
members who are like you're too smart to
be you know being in entertainment doing
whatever uh like well everything that
we're saying that we are you know that
humanity is inherently you know
narrative based i mean everything we
learn from stories that's why i mean we
spend however many hours of our week
you know consuming movies and television
shows everything that we learn is
subconsciously you know coming from the
stories that we are watching and it's so
important and so it always disappointed
me when people were going well why are
you doing that it's like well i feel
like i could be this is the most
important work that i could be doing if
i'm you know leveraging
my craft basically
in a way that is meaningful and that i
think is aligned with my values there's
nothing better because that's the way
that people learn that's the way that
you change minds that's why it's like i
don't
not not want to give up on hollywood but
not want to give up on entertainment and
the power that it holds thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you